[Music]
[Music]
so you just starting your day or did you
just get off they call I go yeah so what
is it you do I'm a driver Oh like a
chauffeur
anyone I'd know Oh
huh what is your name baby your name's
baby Bab why baby
[Music]
this one you say listen to the music all
the time is he a mental mental meaning
slow was he slow no he had an accident
when he was a kid still has a hum in the
drum plays music to drown it out and
that's what makes him the best
[Music]
one more job and I'm done one more job
and we're straight no I don't think I
need to give you the speech what happens
when you say no how I could break your
legs until everyone you love because you
already know that don't you yeah
the moment you catch feelings is the
moment you catch a bullet
and your uh waitress girlfriend she's
cute let's keep it that way I want us to
head west and ever stop he went I'm in
baby
[Music]
[Music]
one of these days baby you're gonna get
blood on your hands
time to face the music baby we need to
get out of here I have to end this are
we in bed together now baby baby
doc said Michael Myers this is Mike
Myers it should be the Halloween Mass
this is a Halloween mask no the killer
dual from Halloween
oh you mean Jason no baby you tell me
who does
she could go home love her yes I do
that's too bad
[Music]